[Musique]
la parole comme si c'est melissa maulin
dupuis cette semaine j'ai envie de vous
parler de juger qu'il faut garder à
l'avant-plan qu'il faut continuer de
marteler qu'ils soient dans les médias
que ce soit dans les médias sociaux
c'est le demande on a d'une justice est
présentement on demande beaucoup la
justice pour jones mais c'est pas la
seule attente de justice qu'on a et
c'est pour ça qu'on on parle beaucoup de
racisme systémique c'est le gros mot du
mois et beaucoup de gens nous reprochent
d'utiliser à 6me système etc et racisme
système mais parce que pour nous qui
sont d'un côté où on voit justin
l'emploi du système et le où il ya des
problématiques de racisme utiliser les
mots adéquats pour ce qui est vécu pour
ce qui est reconnue aussi un peu partout
c'est important et donc quand la
personne qui représente le plus grand
pouvoir dans la province refuse de dire
ses moules
ça devient problématique c'est un refus
de justice pour les communautés qui le
vivent et je me fais même demandé
pourquoi si vous n'avez pas de vouloir
pousser racisme systémique
pourquoi est ce que vous faites pas
justin justice pour durer 10 pourquoi
est-ce que vous parlez pas juste des
qu'aux étudiants parce que
malheureusement ce système le haut des
problématiques de racisme et c'est à
cause de ces problématiques là que l'on
voit des cas comme celui de joyce et
chaque one et contrairement à ce que
beaucoup de gens pensent
c'est très récent que le nom de la
personne qui est victime d'un acte
violent qui en décèdent ou victimes d'un
racisme dans le système se fasse en
temps avant on parlait des femmes
assassinées disparu et c'est pour ça
qu'on a eu une commission denquête quand
ça a été le corps des femmes à val-d'or
et bien fallu un groupe de femmes unis
ensemble avec l'aide du centre d'amitié
de val d'or pour pouvoir faire entendre
la voix des femmes qui devaient parler
des problématiques policière qui
existait dans la ville mais jones et
chaque coin de maintenant son nom existe
dans la mentalité est dans l'imaginaire
québécois
et ça pour moi en tant qu'arme
autochtone c'est vraiment une nouveauté
il faut vraiment travailler fort pour
que les gens se rappellent du nom des
victimes d
des personnes qui sont malheureusement
décédés dans des cas de meurtres mais
aussi dans l'école justement parce que
là on sait pas encore ce que c'est
puisqu'on n'a pas encore eu la justice
qu'il fallait pour parler de la
problématique des deux infirmières qui
ont été filmés mais aussi de parler des
responsabilités par rapport aux gens qui
sont les directeurs par exemple de ce
système
et là je pense à monsieur castonguay qui
lui même a dit j'ai jamais été mis au
courant et pourtant la commission vient
savaient clairement cités l'hôpital de
joliette comme étant un lieu
problématique par rapport au racisme ou
la discrimination systémique et le
quelle est ta responsabilité si
quelqu'un refuse quelqu'un qui est au
pouvoir refuse de dire les deux mots
importants racisme systémique ou même
discrimination systémique et qu'elle
commence que tu peux donner responsable
de la problématique qui est ignorée en
sachant tout les faits en ayant une
commission où vient ce qui vient de dire
regardez un problème peut-être forestier
à temps et de même dire devant leur
public où j'étais pas au courant mais
que des personnes qui avaient été
envoyés et qui avait communiqué
l'information ont dit clairement non je
t'ai mis au courant donc pourquoi est ce
qu'on parle de racisme systémique dans
ce cas là c'est de dire mais pourquoi
est ce que les personnes qui sont
victimes de jeu d'actes d'actes racistes
d'actes de discrimination sont
volontairement ignorée par les personnes
qui pourrait régler le problème
est ce que c'est parce que l'identité de
ces personnes ne peuvent permettre
justement eu négligence qui était
pratiqué pendant très longtemps et même
dire robin je l'ignorais alors c'est
pour ça qu'on est en attente de justice
c'est pour ça qu'on martèle ces mots là
c'est pour ça qu'il faut utiliser les
mots justes pour décrire la situation je
devais au québec que le premier ministre
refuse à le dire je peux comprendre que
c'est un acte politique mais quand on
voit pendant j'ai par exemple les speed
inauguration du futur président des
états unis et la future vice président
des états unis qui disent clairement les
mots racisme système et c'est que ce
concept existe et ce concept a une
valeur et une raison d'être
il s'est même pas uniquement dans les
codes uniquement de santé on va parler
de l'éducation
on a entendu des codes de raciste
systémique qui touchait des jeunes de
montréal
on va parler des pronostics de police
des concepts qui existait dans les
communautés qu'on connaissait comme
leicester liteon justement les tourner à
la belle étoile où on laissait des
personnes autochtones en dehors des
limites de la ville pour qu'ils
reviennent à pied c'est connu depuis le
depuis l'année 2000 et avec les femmes
de valdès est apparue en 2015 et
tranquillement bien audois continue de
faire valider des choses que nous en
hausse et qui sont faites de façon sans
même y penser deux fois c'est comme
valide et donc en acceptant que les mots
racisme systémique existe en acceptant
qu'il faut une justice qui soit un peu
plus poussé pour défaire justement ce
racisme systémique sa part on parle des
coches justement pendant lé travail de
policier dans le travail des infirmiers
dans le travail d'enseignant mais aussi
des fois dans le travail des juges
puisqu'on a eu des juges dans l'écho qui
disait des arrivées qui faisait des
déclarations extrêmement raciste sur les
victimes je pense même au coeur d'une
des femmes qui avaient été mis en prison
pendant cinq jours une femme autochtone
et qu'on avait quand même un peu juste
pour qu'elle vienne témoigner contre la
personne qui l'avait kidnappée poignardé
et excusez moi je rim c'est tellement
ridicule que pour la forcer à témoigner
en cour et que même pendant qu'elle
faisait son témoignage en cour et bien à
lui avait mis des menottes aux pieds
dont la victime d'une agression sexuelle
d'un acte violent et traité comme le
criminel et est forcé de venir témoigner
est ce qu'on peut dire que ces deux
justices à vitesse variable pour les
femmes et pour les femmes autochtones
donc c'est vous comprendrez que on
continue de demander la justice pour
joyce on ignore rapport justement la
situation présente et on va continuer de
demander qu'il y ait des répercussions
car on ne fait pas son travail quand on
refuse d'avouer qu'on n'a pas pris en
compte des situations extrêmement
dangereuses pour les communautés
autochtones
quand des deux infirmières et par
exemple le directeur du csss
non aucune on n'a pas l'impression en
tant que communauté autochtone qui
savent être pris au sérieux on a
l'impression que d'hab sur les doigts
fait le pull et ça dit quoi aux
personnes qui vont loi est un peu
raciste et on parle pas du système qui
va être raciste par des personnes des
individus mais je m'en sortir pas mal
bien et c'est pour ça que pour nous on
ne sera qu'à qu'on insiste sur les mots
qu'on insiste sur le concept parce que
une fois que le concept va être compris
va avoir été décortiqués il va intégrer
justement dans le système
et bien c'est là qu'on va pouvoir
enlever des situations qui sont
malheureusement ignoré par beaucoup de
gens de la population mais qui son
véhicule par une population qui souvent
ni en marge
donc c'est pas pour moi je dis je me
nourris pas la culpabilité des gens mais
par exemple je sens que l'avenir le même
de ma communauté et de plus en plus en
sécurité si on accepte que six concepts
le font partie des réalités des
communautés autochtones et aussi des
réalités des québécois qui ne vivent pas
qu'ils ne subissent pas mais qui y
participent des fois par l'ignorance
joyeuse qu'on peut en avoir cédé je
savais pas et maintenant vous le savez
maintenant il faut accepter que c'était
une réalité un concept et maintenant on
doit transformer la société pour qu'elle
devienne de plus en plus juste donc je
vous invite à partager ses vidéos
souscrite à partager d'ailleurs tout ce
qui va être de la justice pour joyce
puisqu'on doit faire avancer notre
société notre communauté commune et en
plus avancée va la vivre ensemble qui
est de la vue en cette belle semaine
et n'hésitez pas à nous envoyer des
questions